hello how are you welcome back to
another episode of ask iga i just want
to know how you guys are doing and if
you're doing fantastic please type
fantastic in the comments and if you're
not doing fantastic
smile it'll fake yourself into thinking
that you're feeling fantastic
[Music]
all right so i asked you guys on twitter
for some questions and here's what we've
got first up is bo brooks is asking what
would you do with what would i do if i
found a million dollars on the street
first thing that comes to mind drug deal
second thing that comes to mind
somebody's dead third thing that comes
to mind is i'm taking this and i'm going
to the apple store and i'm buying
everything there i mean let's be real
but the real answer to that question is
i have no idea what i would do i would
probably crap myself little monsters
asking if i like lady gaga and it's
funny that you actually ask if i like
her because i was thinking the other day
what's this girl been up to i don't know
if she's on tour
food is here i'll be right back
i gotta go get my food because i don't
know how to cook myself so i'm walking
down the stairs you guys can't see me
but you can probably hear me
[Music]
hi
how are you good thank you thank you
me too
[Music]
food's here whoa don't think i answer
the last question but doesn't really
matter katy perry oh my god katy perry
thank you so much for asking me a
question let's ask ij how did you know
that i loved you so much katie wants to
know he was more competitive you jenna
or brie this stupid necklace is never
centered and no my chest is not pierced
it's a necklace brienne is definitely
the most competitive i don't really care
either way i like to win actually when
i'm playing call of duty i'm pretty
competitive but everything else in life
i don't really care i don't care just
don't care jenna she's kind of somewhere
in the middle michelle britty
naked want to know if you saw me on a
taco bell commercial yes you did what's
so crazy is i absolutely love doritos
like i'm obsessed and when they first
came out with our doritos tacos like the
normal ones i tweeted something about
how i really wish they had cooler ranch
doritos and guess what a couple years
later not only do they have my favorite
doritos but i mean the commercial i mean
that's like freaking
awesome i love tacos i love doritos
[Music]
fix yourself hair fix
yourself my goodness i'm such a pig
kyle is asking if i've ever traveled
business or first class when traveling
so i never actually realized how
terrible that they treat you at the
airlines until i flew first class i got
up to the checkout counter and this one
was so mean like she i thought was going
to stab me or cut me or i don't even
know she was not having a good day until
she ran my card and realized that i was
first class let me tell you what this
girl she did a freaking 360. she went
from
to oh my goodness how are you justine
missy's eric how are you doing today can
i get you anything can i maybe get you
some planted flowers or maybe a easter
bonnet is she gonna jump over this
counter and make lip contact with my
lips like her lips on my lips kissing me
because i am first class
up in the sky a popping champagne
living life
let's just move right along cody wants
to know if i'm excited to get my new
google glass yes i am super excited that
i got chosen to be one of the very few
who will be getting to try the new
project glass the eyes of what google
see i don't know the future scares me
but i'm excited for it and i can't wait
to get my google glasses and i'm going
to wear them all the time and i'm going
to look so fly libby wants to know what
would i do if i was given purple ice
cream i would eat it i'd eat it right
there on the spot hannah wants to know
if i'm doing veda veda which is vlog
every day in april i'll either be
posting them on my youtube.com slash
other justine channel or my youtube.com
slash ijustine's iphone oh the irony
because this is my iphone guys i want to
get this ask ij episode done right now
because i want to eat that food that i
have in that bag i want to eat the food
i want to eat the food that's in the
bath in the one in the bag i want to eat
the food what crazy hair color would you
like to have the most i
would like to have purple hair go figure
why do you order most things online
instead of going out to your local
stores to get the stuff that you order
well i'm lazy
you like the iphone so much so what are
your top reasons not to buy the samsung
galaxy 4 iphone iphone iphone iphone
iphone those are my top reasons although
i'm not opposed to any of the samsung
phones because they're actually pretty
sweet and i've seen them in person in
real life out in the wild and i'm always
like wow
that looks real sweet
wow
but for now i'm gonna stick with my
iphone because
i love it
harry potter oh my gosh
harry potter i can't believe you were
submitting me an ask ij episode question
i got harry potter and freaking katy
perry today i did in fact get luigi's
mansion too i haven't put it down yet
that's a lie i've put it down now to
shoot this episode where's my food i
want to eat the food
looks like we're out of questions thank
you guys for watching this episode of
ask ij
hey
you asked ij i'm gonna go eat my food
i'll see you guys in my next episode
make sure you guys like this episode and
don't forget to subscribe so you'll see
when i post a new video even though even
if you're subscribed you sometimes don't
see them i love you and i'll see you
later
we fly in first class look in the sky a
puppy champagne i'm gonna eat my food
now
[Music]